[Music]
hey what's going on hot winds fans this
is shawn evans coming at you from the
hop ones museum of curiosities where at
the end of every season we answer your
hard-hitting end-of-season hotlines fan
questions and this year there were two
burning controversial topics that we'll
hit on first as we enter controversy
corner
number one on that list the wall of
shame what happened to the wall of shame
well
i'll try to break this down as best i
can to open things up this is far from a
perfect analogy but there's that thing
about the wrong laugh that dave
chappelle thing about the wrong laugh
and i kind of felt like that was
happening with the wall of shame where i
think people are taking the wall of
shame literally and kind of thinking
well if you don't eat a wing with
scorpion disco you should actually be
shamed for it i like some of the tap out
episodes like to me lil yachty ricky
gervais those are still to this day two
of my favorite episodes so it's already
hard to book this show where we have
celebrities eating scorching on chicken
wings then you have you know if you
don't get through the gauntlet an angry
mob dunking on you in a way that isn't
really super positive or doesn't serve
the show at all so it's like wall of
shame
scrap it up
throw it in the garbage
then
i got a tweet that i thought was kind of
interesting where this person was like
what the hell olivia rodrigo got through
the gauntlet and she thought a bell
pepper was spicy bring back the wall of
shame you guys are soft
and i was like
all right well that sort of makes sense
to me so here's my position on the wall
of shame going forward we will bring it
back on a probationary period but the
second i start getting tagged and things
at scale that are dark and weird and way
too emotional and angry and rageful
wall of shame is done and it's done
forever so ball is in your court we play
nice with it we keep the wall of shame
it starts to get weird and dark again
it's all over it's all over so you guys
have the power the second thing two
tables so when the two table things
started off uh was just a way to satisfy
the safety guidelines the lawyers etc to
get back into the studio and i'm like
the youtube audience you know like you
change anything about a youtube show
people freak out and i'm kind of like
that so i kind of do try to protect
everything about hot ones as much as i
can and at first i was like it's got to
be one table it's got to be one table
but what i've found from going through
the two table thing is that i actually
prefer the two table setup the distance
is a much more natural and comfortable
distance to do an interview and then the
projection of your voice it translates
to video so much better i look at old
episodes me and joey diaz are like six
inches away from each other's face the
talking's almost like whispering sure
like when people are going through hot
sauce moments it gets kind of loud but i
don't know the future like how this
thing goes maybe it's jonas brothers
table but maybe just two table setup i
love the two table setup all right well
there you have it controversy corner
those questions addressed as thoroughly
as i can but now it's time to dig into
some of the more nuanced some of the
more niche some of the more specialized
hot ones fan questions dom hit me with
the bucket
let's dive right in
out of all the guests you've had on hot
ones which is the one that you were glad
you got before they reach their current
level of fame there's a genre of hot
ones interviewed that i love which is
kind of like um you know maybe they're
not the first interview of record but
maybe the first or close to the first
interview of record for a lot of these
pop stars that have done this just sort
of meteoric rise to the top and there
are four that stand out in my mind so
that would be most recently in this
season the olivia rodrigo episode but i
also really compare that episode to ones
that we've done in the past with shawn
mendes billy eilish and even post malone
i feel like they were just on their way
to just taking over the pop world and we
caught them at a really interesting time
in their lives and in their careers so
those four interviews um i value as sort
of a genre unto themselves all right up
next
have you ever played game consoles
before if so what was your first system
you had that's from nationverse8472
i'm old as [ __ ]
listen dude i'm i'm old i remember my
nintendo nes christmas i remember my
sega genesis christmas so yeah i played
consoles before all right up next
do you have any tricks of the trade or
guiding principles to use when balancing
the need to be present in an interview
versus the temptation to edit in your
head to make sure you get what you need
that's from tanner britt
actually an awesome question i have this
debate with myself all the time because
you can get into kind of a bad habit of
editing the episode in real time and
then it's like oh i know how that wing's
going to play out because i've sat
through 10 million of these edits over
the years it's really easy to kind of
turn the page and go on to the next
thing but you don't want to be so
mathematical in the way that you're
engaging and connecting to another
person so that is forever a battle that
goes on in the head of an interviewer
you don't want it to be so transactional
like got what we need from you great now
we move on you actually want to connect
and have that rhythm and build that
story of each individual shoot so that's
always the goal but
i'd be lying to myself if i said that
you don't
fight with yourself internally at least
a little bit when it comes to that kind
of internal debate all right up next
earl the actor asks what's your favorite
place to dine in evanston so uh i used
to go to northwestern games all the time
with my dad and my brother and then
afterwards we'd go to hackneys because
they have this onion brick so i always
remember hackney's fondly because it was
part of that saturday in the fall going
to ryan field watching the wildcats and
then afterwards going to hackney so i'll
go with hackneys officially
since it's been a few seasons since
we've had a fellow youtuber on hot ones
have you thought about interviewing more
youtubers or even possibly popular
twitch streamers so here's how i look at
this thing now i don't think of
youtubers as any different from
mainstream celebrities like there are
youtubers youtubers that have network
talk shows and are in movies and then
you have conventional movie stars that
start youtube channels so to me at this
point it's become so interchangeable
basically what we look at is is when
we're pitching a guest who's got a book
coming out who's got a movie coming out
who's got a show coming out where do we
need to update the pitch where can we
try a different strategy and then all of
those things kind of work to get a guest
to finally sit in the seat and eat the
scorching hot chicken wings so um maybe
it's been a little youtuber light but i
think that in future seasons maybe it'll
be a little youtuber heavy but i don't
differentiate uh between those things
all right up next
colin kurtz asks what is your favorite
book that was written by a guest on hot
ones i can't just pick one let me just
shout out my top five i like talking to
strangers by malcolm gladwell i like
born a crime by trevor noah i like not
taco bell material by adam carolla i
like
yearbook by seth rogen i like green
lights by matthew mcconaughey and then
an honorable mention to professional
idiot by stevo and life will be the
death of me by chelsea handler naomi
campbell coffee table book
also amazing we can't clear the cover
art though i'll tell you that right now
federocker asks is there someone that
you personally wanted on the show that
have been denied by the showrunners in
some capacity i love this question
because it implies that there's any sort
of structure to this operation
whatsoever a showrunner i don't know
what a showrunner is it might be a shock
to everyone watching but shonda rhimes
is not standing behind that monitor i
can see who's behind that monitor it is
not shonda rhimes but so basically
though how it works is if it ever comes
down to a debate there's basically like
three people that have a vote and so we
all have a key so if two people put in
the key and turn it then that's a yes if
only one person or nobody puts in the
key then that's kind of a no although
those sorts of debates don't come up all
that often so no show runner still just
a small operation and speaking of that
operation our little island of misfit
toys over here i think it's time that we
check in with bill and see how his
summer's been going hey bill
bill
oh
hey there shawn looks like you caught me
finishing up my afternoon nap oh i've
been up since 6 am tending to my slow
cooked wings
would you look at that it's time for a
nice cold course light
[Music]
this summer i've been perfecting the
perfect recipe for summer chill that's
why i moved my tent next to my grill so
i'd never have to leave the key to
making the perfect smoked wing is
cooking them slow and long there's
nothing quite like sleeping out under
the stars for the smell of smoked meat
and sipping on a nice cool coors light
excuse me sean i have to check on my
wings
[Music]
not done yet
[Music]
looks like i'm gonna be here a
while camera guy bill keeping the lights
on over here all right let's get back to
the bucket
jonathan asks what's last tv show or
film you enjoyed watching
this year i liked willy's wonderland i
liked zola
i liked the bob odenkirk movie nobody i
liked black widow i like still water and
then last night you know what sometimes
you forget how kick-ass some movies are
i watched gone girl last night that
movie is awesome all right approaching
the bottom of the bucket
when picking guests would you rather be
someone who watches slash enjoys hot
ones already or someone who never saw it
and how it goes also lord is my mvp for
this season so far no argument there i'm
kind of both like i'll i'll pull two
examples from this season so um uh david
harbor for example is a guy that had no
idea really what he was getting himself
into and i love that episode because you
can see him
fall into hot ones in such a magical way
gets drunk off the hot sauce and it's
exactly how we draw it up but i'll tell
you one thing you know in the early days
everybody was like kind of walking in
looking at it sideways like what is this
freak show and that was never fun
because then you'd have to kind of dig
yourself out of that hole and then
they'd kind of get it and then you'd
have a good thing going but that
beforehand when i'm just sort of like
sitting there on set by myself uh with
these wings and sort of the embarrassing
black curtain set that was never kind of
that was never fun now when we have
people walk in and their kids watch it
or they've seen the episodes or whatever
that is so much better than how it used
to be i'll tell you that
well there you have it it's another hot
ones fan q a in the books as you know
you get the drill at this point 15
seasons in when we say goodbye to one
season we're just waving in the next
season to port so season 16 will be just
around the corner in the meantime lots
of surprises truth or dabs hot sauce
reveal and then of course the season 16
premiere thank you so much for watching
this season it means the world to us
coming out of the quarantine episodes
seen the way fans have rallied around
the show i can't tell you what it means
to us that work at hot ones until then
though hot ones for
life
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is shawn evans checking in with a quick
reminder of the hot ones season 15
sauces are currently available at
heatness.com that's right heatness.com
to get your hands on the season 15 hot
sauces i know you're sitting there
you're wondering at home like oh it
can't be that hot i think they're
overdoing it they're exaggerating i've
had spicy before i can do it we'll put
it to the test
now available heatness.com heatness.com
to get your hands on the season 15 hot
sauces
be careful around the eyes